[Music]
welcome to the livestream huge show a
lot of people won't like it lot to
discuss I'm gonna talk a little bit
about more indictments coming I talked
on the regular broadcast show today and
I will explain what was going on with a
hair today on the broadcast show talked
on the broadcast show today Michael
Flynn now enough evidence to indict him
reportedly according to NBC News Robert
Mulder has the evidence indictment of
Michael Flynn upcoming not surprising
he's been at the top of our list for a
while and that's what's gonna happen so
we'll get to that but I really more
broadly today want to talk about how
there are really two stories Trump
Russia is one but also the recent DNC
Donna Brazile revelations they're really
making the left its destroy itself and I
am very very worried about what's going
on with the left so first and foremost
welcome if this is your first live
stream with me then yes these are really
live unless you're watching a replay and
they are archived for your viewing
pleasure after the fact you can send
questions ask comments I will react to
comments and answer your questions
super chat is one way that is the dollar
sign at the bottom of the chat window
the other option is stream labs at
stream labs comm slash the David Pakman
show the latter option circumvents
youtube taking 30 percent okay but use
either one both are available new
patrons and members of course will be
thanked by me live during the stream you
can find out more about that at the two
URLs listed here big patreon news many
of you of course already aware of it we
are all also now accepting
cryptocurrency Bitcoin aetherium and
litecoin info at david pakman.com slash
cryptocurrency
and please don't troll for the the
upshot today is that nobody was banned
before the stream started so that i know
it's a pretty damn low bar that i'm
setting but please no obvious trolling
because there are moderators and you
will be banned so let's jump right into
it or actually i guess first well yeah
let's jump right into it we'll deal with
we'll deal with this a little bit later
okay and a lot of confusion
about what's going on but this relates
to this right so anyway we'll get back
to that later so listen this Trump
Russia thing has been going on for a
while now and all along there have been
people on the left and on the right
saying there's no story here now the
idea that there still might be no story
not really a credible perspective right
I mean we have at this point three
indictments in a guilty plea these are
not contrary to what Sean Spicer
previously told us about Paul mana Ford
contrary to what Sarah Huckabee Sanders
said about George papadopolis
these were not interns getting coffee
okay Paul Manafort was Donald Trump's
campaign chairman for some time Rick
gates his associate George papadopolis
even though he's being written off as
just some young kid who was doing some
foreign policy advice without getting
paid Trump himself had Papadopoulos at a
table with him and Jeff Sessions during
which we now know on March 31st 2016
Russia related possibilities were
discussed we know that Donald Trump
mentioned George papadopolis unprovoked
listed him proactively during a radio
interview as a top foreign policy
adviser and a great person so forget
about the idea that the people that have
been indicted so far are minor players
but that's really the story right the
fact that we have multiple indictments
and the Trump team is just trying to
write it all off as these are minor
players that tells us that it is a story
we learned over the weekend and I
reported to you today that former
disgraced former national security
adviser Michael Flynn and I couldn't we
could do an hour just on why he was
disgraced and compromised he now
reportedly is getting indicted and this
is going to be another step up right
we're going from former campaign manager
and foreign policy advisor who were only
with Trump during the campaign to former
national security adviser Michael Flynn
who actually worked for Trump yes it was
only twenty four days before he was
forced to resign / fire - call it
whatever you want to call it but now
we're getting into the White House right
Flynn as I said on the program today
worked in the West Wing
across the hall or whatever
I don't know exactly what the
arrangement of the offices is but the
Oval offices is though in the West Wing
of the White House and the National
Security Adviser works in the left in
the West Wing of the White House now as
up as a pre-emptive measure you were
going to hear very likely from the right
from the Trump administration to
defenses for what appears to be the
pending indictment of Michael Flynn
number one you were going to hear oh
Obama hired Flynn Trump only hired Flynn
because he thought hey if Obama had him
then he was fine which of course is
[ __ ] right President Obama
proactively and specifically Warren
Warren Donald Trump against hiring
Michael Flynn and said Flynn's
compromised Trump did it anyway and the
number two defense that you're going to
hear is listen this is not that big
because after all National Security
Adviser isn't a cabinet member that's
true but what difference does that make
it's going higher and higher and higher
and so pre-empting those are two likely
defenses you'll hear I don't think
you'll hear the defense what if and when
Michael Flynn's indictment happens I
don't think you're going to hear the
defense that he wasn't really a big
player like the hole he was just kind of
like an intern volunteer type I don't
think you'll hear that I think you'll
hear other defenses or apologia call
them whatever you want okay so that
that's sort of like the precursor but
here's what I'm really worried about
this fracturing of the left is really
getting bad and it's happening on a few
different issues let's go through them
one by one
and I'm going to be I will be taking all
the questions I'm just I'm not gonna
interrupt while I'm doing this but I
will take all questions via super chat &
stream labs it will all happen we'll
talk about the hair situation and
everything okay
one situation which generally speaking
has been pulling the left apart has been
the DNC not being a fair arbiter during
the Democratic primary I was a supporter
of Bernie Sanders during the primary I
voted for Hillary Clinton in the general
election I believe that there is
evidence that there was Trump Russia
collusion and yet
I believe that yes the DNC had a
favorite the favorite was Hillary
Clinton and they worked in a number of
ways in a number of ways to make it
easier for Hillary Clinton to secure the
nomination and more difficult for anyone
else to do it
anyone else mostly was Bernie because
that's the one other Democratic
candidate that got traction over the
weekend or late last week and I did an
hour livestream about it we learned
about Donna Brazile former interim DNC
party chairman DNC chair chairwoman
her allegations which coincided with the
release of a book which clearly she
wants to sell copies of said I
investigated and yes Hillary Clinton
stole the primary from Bernie Sanders
and the revelations were on the one hand
shocking and on the other hand
unsurprising right it's shocking to see
it said so clearly but it's also not
surprising if you follow it everything
that was going on and I read the
allegations and I read the follow-up
about the joint fundraising agreements
and everything else and I'll sort of
very quickly restate what I said on the
program today which is yes Hillary
Clinton had an agreement with the DNC
that was not the same as the one Bernie
Sanders had that's a defense we've heard
hey nothing to see here Bernie had a jfa
just like Hillary Clinton had a jfa but
Bernie opted not to enact it because his
whole thing was I'm doing small donors
and blah blah blah blah blah that's not
true okay
they both had Jay FAS but Hillary
Clinton had another agreement above and
beyond that that did allow for all sorts
of other control and other things but
that's where I think we're getting into
a problem the left now is getting into a
debate over how bad was the DNC working
with Hillary Clinton was it as bad as
Donna Brazile says it was or was it not
quite as bad etc and it's a major
distraction from the reality that the
Democratic Party is not functioning as a
vehicle for progressive politics the
Democratic Party is effectively
Democrats Inc which I've been talking
about for a long time right the sort of
establishment corporate party and if we
don't start working on fixing that it's
going to be sort of irrelevant to what
degree the
and Hillary Clinton worked together I am
NOT for a second denying that the DNC
clearly favored Hillary Clinton it was
not an unbiased arbiter of the DNC I
have at every point have said that do
not think for a second that I am denying
that right not at all not not even a
tiny bit but what I'm saying is the
exact degree how trustworthy Donna
Brazile is and I'm getting emails from
people saying she this woman is not
trustworthy she's trying to sell book
with the most salacious possible
headlines and others saying we finally
found out the truth from Donna Brazile
what I'm telling you is don't focus on
that right now and it's not about it
doesn't matter because it was in the
past right we've heard from Hillary
Clinton this was in the past let's get
beyond it kind of funny that she wrote a
memoir talking all about what happened
and blaming Bernie for some stuff but
now she's saying what's in the past
doesn't matter anyway I'm not telling
you what's in the past doesn't matter
what I'm telling you is yes the DNC was
not a fair arbiter of the primary and
nothing has been done to prevent it from
happening again Tom Perez is the DNC
Party Chairman and the left is fractured
and this is not going to fix any of the
problems that Democrats are having
that's number one issue 2 which is
destroying the Left that's making the
left sort of eat itself is Trump Russia
and the connection is to Bernie Sanders
and Hillary Clinton and here's sort of
the way it works right
when we first learned about the
possibility of Trump Russia collusion
there were some committed Bernie brave
voters who resisted acknowledging that
hey we don't know yet it's very early
this was a while ago it's very early but
it's possible that Russia was involved
in trying to help Donald Trump win the
election now two points on this at the
time this was only with regard to
influencing the election results now
that influence is only a tiny piece of
everything that's going on with Trump
Russia right so that that's part of the
frustration of why this is so so so
damaging to the to the left because
we've moved well beyond just did Russian
involvement flipped the election
but at the time that was the question
and there would some some very committed
Bernie Sanders supporters who felt that
if they acknowledge that Russia may have
played a role or attempted to play a
role or was in cahoots with the Trump
administration or was manipulating
Donald Trump the Trump campaign not
Administration that in some way it says
Bernie wasn't a great candidate and
Hillary was better right and this is
where we went off the rails just
acknowledging that Russia tried to
influence the campaign even if and I
don't believe that this was necessarily
the case but even if it was true that
Hillary Clinton would have won were it
not for Russian interference and again
I'm not saying that's the case but even
if that were true that doesn't mean
Bernie is any worse of a candidate I
voted for Bernie Sanders in the primary
my confidence in Bernie Sanders as the
best candidate in the Democratic primary
would not in any way be impacted if I
found out that were it not for Russian
interference Hillary Clinton would have
won so that is issue number one where
the left started to divide on Trump
Russia it's since gotten much much worse
and sadly I'm still getting emails from
some people saying David there is no
story here and at a certain point it's
starting to become delusional it's
starting to become delusional to say
that after we have Rex Tillerson
connected to Russia Jared Kushner
connected to yuri milner
expose i did on that on today's
programme paradise' papers expose that
in some detail Commerce Secretary Wilbur
Ross connected to Russia won't go
through the details now I talked about
that on today's program as well we have
the Trump jr. I'll be covering this
tomorrow we he went now his original
story was the the lawyer the Russian
lawyer meeting in Trump Tower was
nothing it was so nothing that I don't
even remember anything about it it was
nothing with this lawyer in Natalya
vessel it's kaya we've now learned that
vessel it's kaya has testified that
during the meeting Donald Trump jr.
intimated that
number one well first of all he asked
for written proof of the hillary dirt
that Natalia vessel Mnet's gaya claimed
to have and number two he implied
intimated that if they can get the dirt
and if ultimately Donald Trump becomes
president of the United States they
might be willing to change or attempt to
change that Magnitsky law 2012 2012 or
2002 now I don't remember law which is
effectively a political quid pro quo
offering to a hostile foreign nation
okay so I could go on and on and on the
long and short of it is at this point if
you are still in the camp of those
individuals who believes that there is
no story if you're on the right I get it
and I don't care I'm not even talking to
you I'm talking to the left because I'm
worried about the left eating itself
over these two stories the the Donna
Brazile DNC Bernie Hillary stuff which
is a story again I'm not saying it's not
a story but what I'm telling you is that
it's being handled by the left in a way
that's disastrous and Trump Russia and
the the main focus that I think I want
to stick with is that Trump Russia
collusion to whatever extent that
existed does not devalue Bernie Sanders
as a candidate I'm with you he was the
best candidate from the beginning period
don't be blind to trump Russia collusion
just because you feel like it would be
an attack on Bernie Sanders or a defense
of Hillary Clinton because it wouldn't
be it wouldn't be either okay let me get
to some of the questions that are coming
in I do want to explain this though a
lot of people are starting to see the
clips that came out today from the
broadcast show and wondering did I stick
my finger in a light socket
why does my hair look this way and the
answer is quite simple I agreed I
pledged to you months ago that when we
reached 2,000 patrons at patreon.com
slash david pakman show that I would do
one day of a broadcast show with my hair
uncontrolled we recently reached the
2,000 patron mark in fact we were at
20/20 right now
and so I kept my word and I immediately
went into the studio and risked all
sorts of labor relations and OSHA claims
by producer pat for subjecting him to
these work conditions with my hair like
this but I did it because I promised
that I would and that's that that is
that we are now moving on to the patreon
jenga scheme and this will be where I
think starting tomorrow we're doing it
we're gonna go back several days we will
be doing a Jenga game I've got a Jenga
tower as I've been told it's called on
my desk now and for everybody who has
contributed we will be pulling we will
be pulling Jenga pieces off and then
there will be membership specials tied
to when the tower falls bla bla bla bla
bla long story short I would love it if
you made a patreon contribution during
the livestream you can also sign up for
a membership these are our primary
funding sources and sadly this it's just
been one disaster after another this
year at the beginning of April we had
YouTube D monetization which took like
99% of our YouTube ad revenue we've
since recovered some portion of that but
it's still very bad we've got like 30%
of the revenue back and we were starting
to claw back with memberships and
patreon and then last Monday Amazon cut
our Amazon affiliate link we used to
have this link david pakman.com slash
amazon which would redirect you to
amazon and when you bought stuff we got
a little kickback amazon shut that down
they shut down a bunch of other
progressive and conservative shows as
well as well I don't believe it's a
political thing it's just a money thing
and if you go to that page now you'll
just see a message explaining what
happened so we we've been hit pretty
hard this year and we're doing
everything we can you know we had we had
major plans to grow actually this year
and it now we are sort of in emergency
mode where we're trying to figure out
well how can we just recover the lost
revenue first so we're trying to do that
a few different ways let me get into
some of the questions that are being
asked here the d2j bug sent a $5 Super
chat asking where's the kaboom there was
supposed to be an earth-shattering
kaboom
I don't know what that means
unfortunately I'm not sure a user named
dear Putin please delete my peepee tape
sent a five-dollar superjet when do you
think molar will release my peepee tape
well this is referring to the alleged
existence of I from the Russian
blackmail dossier which more and more of
has now been confirmed although not the
P allegations there were assertions made
in it that Donald Trump sort of was into
urine as a sexual fetish and and
possibly even in connection with Russian
prostitutes I don't know anything about
that I don't know and it's sort of a
distraction from from the bigger picture
of what's going on but yes it is it is
something that any day might break and
if it does I'm sure we will be analyzing
it like the Zapruder film of course
Stephen anter sent a $2.00 contribution
at stream labs.com slash the david
packard show why are there no
conservative comics now i don't know if
you mean comic strips or comedians if
you mean mean comic strips i thought
that there were like isn't isn't dooms
very kind of right-wing and Scott Adams
from Dilbert I thought he was a trump
supporter if you met comedians what
about uh what about that guy Jim Norton
who I think is terrible
and completely unfunny isn't he a right
wing nut I don't remember now but that's
one guy anyway
Kristina sent a dollar stream Labs
contribution stream labs.com slash the
David Pakman show
I was hoping your hair would still be a
fluff side note you should take Kyle of
secular talk shopping his suit jackets
are not so stylish I will say it like
that Wow I don't know Kyle's wearing
over on secular talk but I probably
won't look into it but I am more than
willing next time I see Kyle to give him
the name of my tailor if he's interested
Klaus m54 has sent a three dollar and
forty eight cents super stream lapse
contribution do you think Trump will be
able to use the trip to Asia to distract
from the investigation at least for some
time
I think he'll try you know that I don't
I don't go in the direction of false
flags okay I don't I don't do this but I
do think it is very interesting to
consider that the right particularly the
conspiratorial right is you
accusing the left of the false flags but
really when you look at motivation it's
the right that has the circumstances
that would imply they would want to do
the false flags I'll give you two
examples number one anytime there's a
shooting for example when President
Obama was president and there was a mass
shooting the right would say some of the
right a fraction of the right right the
conspiratorial right I'm not casting
this net so wide to include the entire
right they would say this was a false
flag organized by Obama or his
associates to create a pretext for the
taking of guns from people and of course
that wasn't that didn't happen right
there were there was no taking of guns
from people under President Obama and in
fact a Democratic president served as a
great gun sales catalyst the NRA and
other groups would say Obama the
Democrat is going to take your guns so
go and buy more guns and people did gun
sales are down under Donald Trump so if
anybody did have an incentive to create
a false flag gun attack mass shooting to
justify or foment the sales of guns it
would actually be those who want more
guns sold including the NRA including
the right just saying I'm not saying
that's what's going on but what I'm
telling you is those are the motivations
that would actually suggest that someone
might do a false flag because again
Obama took no guns similarly if you were
trying to distract from multiple
indictments in an investigation looking
into how if and how you might have
colluded or been manipulated or
compromised by a hostile foreign country
you might take a trip but you also would
have reason to take attention away by
focusing the media 24/7 or close to 24/7
on a mass shooting so again I am NOT
alleging that any false Flags took place
but what I'm telling you is if you
believe in that stuff you should really
be considering the multiple incentives
that the conspiratorial right would have
for those events to take place just say
let's look at the next Super chat which
or no I'm sorry let's look at the next
stream lapse contribution at stream labs
comm slash the david pakman show seltzer
boy has sent a $3 stream lapse
contribution why don't you support the
Justice Democrats if you had cancer you
take chemotherapy right how is this any
different I don't know what you're
talking about I've been asked generally
about primary Democrats rather than
running against Republicans I've said
sometimes it makes sense sometimes it
doesn't in a world of limited resources
you've got to be pragmatic practical and
consider what the possible unintended
consequences are of choosing to primary
certain Democrats I've never said
anything negative period about justice
Democrats full stop
so I don't I don't fully know what it is
you're talking about Natalie at stream
labs.com slash the david pakman show has
sent a $3 contribution what is your
opinion about the disparity in the
reaction of Trump over how he reacted
towards the incidence in the Vegas
attack and now to Texas attack versus
how he reacted to the New York attack
yeah I mean listen this is not this is a
common piece of the right-wing
inflammatory reactionary playbook right
which is when it's a domestic terrorist
a white dude terrorist the reaction is
sad mental health is the focus prayers
in this case the victims were praying in
a Christian Church so the idea of
prayers is a little odd but prayers
there's no broader issue that we have to
look at when it comes to legislation
when it's a Muslim perpetrator or a
foreign perpetrator as was the case with
the New York incident immediately it's
the it was an animal it was a terrorist
act as opposed to an evil act as Donald
Trump described the incident in Texas we
need a travel ban we need deport a
whatever right all of a sudden it's
legislative solutions that we need so
yeah you're spot on Natalie that there
is a major major hypocrisy in terms of
how these incidents are responded to a
user named subreddit has sent a $2
stream labs contribution hey David can
you add a new sticky on the subreddit
for us to suggest other shows or
podcasts for you to go on
okay lemme I will do that in a bit
sub reddit thread for podcasts and shows
to go on you have to remember I can't
just show up and go on any podcast right
they have to invite me that that's just
I want to mention that that's that's a
reality okay
let's head back over to super chat from
Stream Labs tech dive TV has sent a $10
super check do you predict that Donald
Trump will be indicted if so when I
don't believe Donald Trump will be
indicted I believe that if the
indictments continue and there's every
indication that they're going to in
Trump Russia bingo as I'm calling it and
it starts to get to the point of maybe
reaching Trump that he would resign I
think that he would resign I don't
believe he would be indicted and also
there are lots of legal questions as to
whether you can indict a sitting
president on criminal charges what type
it's it's kind of a mess I think if it
gets to that point it's much more likely
that Donald Trump would resign and sort
of cut the possibility of an impeachment
that that's my sense tech dive Robert
Monroe with the hi super chat of the
evening with a $20 super chat saying
just excellent points well thanks Robert
appreciate the compliment and really
appreciate your contribution and on that
note let me do a couple of thank yous
the the program which by the way is on
200 broadcast stations and DirecTV and
Dish Network is mostly sponsored by
memberships and patreon contributions
and memberships are we have a couple of
new members that I want to thank Tara
Lord has signed up at david pakman.com
slash membership Tara thank you really
appreciate that you're doing a great
thing Jack Hess Jack Hess has signed up
at david pakman.com slash membership
using the 40% off code I voted 17 and
Mark Carter mark Carter has signed up at
david pakman.com slash membership
membership benefits include the bonus
show the commercial free all access pass
and much more you can read about it on
our website you can save 40% with I vote
17 and I can't overstate enough the
importance of these memberships I mean
there there would just be no show if
there were no members that's it's now at
this point the program has been on for
awhile and it can sometimes get lost
because the program has a larger
following but if members all canceled
the show is over
I mean overnight that's it and sort of
what I on is the idea that since we
don't have one boss but instead we have
all these members that there is no one
person who overnight could pull us off
the air the way quite frankly would be
the case if if we were a corporate a
corporate media show I would love it if
we started getting some new patreon
contributions during the stream we
started at 2020 we are still there can
we get to 2035 can we get 50 new patreon
contributors during this live stream
we've got at this point about 650 people
that are with us that means that if just
2% of you two two and a half percent of
you throw in just $1 that's all we're
really looking for at patreon.com slash
David Pakman show
we'll hit 2035 and if we do I will
create and announce a coupon code for
you and it will be a major membership
discount code let's just get to 2035
just 15 that's two point three percent
of the people currently watching the
stream and I think that that would be a
really nice thing why not write let's uh
let's do it let's get that going a
couple other stories that we're going to
be talking about on the program tomorrow
and by the way if you've not seen any of
the clips from today's show a lot of
really good stuff including a very
in-depth analysis of the new Trump
Republican tax plan we go into detail
tax brackets changes or lack thereof
when it comes to retirement
contributions standard deduction
personal exemption estate tax
we're digging deep and members already
have access to that but the standalone
clip clip will be up later today I
believe Donald Trump tomorrow on the
program we will be talking about Donald
Trump after the attack the horrible
attack in New York a few days ago Donald
Trump
the statement that he is that they are
hitting Isis harder and the Pentagon has
not been able to corroborate that and
they would know right so yet more lies
from Donald Trump this time related to
hitting Isis harder after the New York
terrorist attack we'll talk about that
on the program tomorrow we've received
word that the FBI is indeed
investigating the sketchy power contract
that was given in Puerto Rico to
Whitefish Energy it's since been
cancelled but there is a report from
Reuters that the FBI is investigating
that that would be great news and we're
going to talk about that Donald Trump
has made the phrase drain the swamp sort
of a hallmark of his campaign and of
course he's been filling the swamp and
there's a very interesting study that
looked at what percentage of Trump
nominees that are subject to Senate
confirmation right so they just looked
at the subset of all nominees and
appointments that are subject to Senate
confirmation how many of them have a
conflicts of interest financial
conflicts of interest related to the
industries they're supposed to be
regulating and it's more than 50% more
than 50% so the degree of swamp filling
that we've been seeing with the Trump
administration is stunning I hope to
talk to you about that tomorrow and also
many of you have been encouraging me to
investigate this system for purging
people from voter rolls called
cross-check we've looked into a study
specifically in the state of Indiana
that looked at cross-check and it turns
out that 99 99 percent of the people
that the cross check system pulled off
of the voter rolls were incorrectly
incorrectly removed from the voter rolls
99 percent can you imagine a system
supposedly meant to prevent people from
voting twice and whatever right it's all
a great system meant to do great things
99 percent of the people actually purged
from voter rolls
are incorrectly removed so we'll be
covering that tomorrow and I think that
will be an interesting story as well
well let's go over to our stream lapse
comments a user who goes by the name
Melania hates bullies sent a $3 stream
Labs contribution at stream Labs comm
slash the david pakman show saying do
you think Trump is afraid to visit the
DMZ DMZ to deem the demilitarized zone
between North and South Korea I don't
know the answer to that and I don't know
if Trump is scheduled to visit the DMZ
during this Asia trip I don't know if
someone knows feel free to mention that
be a super chatter stream lapse I don't
know if he's afraid and I don't know if
he is even scheduled to be visiting the
DMZ I would be scared I would be scared
to visit the DMZ
I guess well I guess more so I'd be I
would not visit North Korea I mean the
amount of critical reporting I've done
on North Korea over the years even if
it's only like a 2% chance that I'm on
some lists they're the last thing I want
to do is get stuck in North Korea under
any circumstances for any reason
particularly because I might end up in a
prison of some kind let's see what other
comments and questions we have coming in
here a user named Smeg has sent a $5
stream Labs contribution keep up the
good work much love from Scotland thank
you I have never been to Scotland I've
got a number of friends who have
Scottish ancestry and I certainly be
interested in going to Scotland it's not
on my I've got nothing booked to go to
Scotland let me put it that way but
hopefully someday and Chris Harris sent
the $2 super chat with no question or
comment thanks very much appreciate the
support let's take a look at some of the
questions and comments in the regular
chat I don't want to do the elitist
thing of only addressing questions and
comments from super chat let's see what
we've got going on there what questions
do we have
do I think molar would indict Trump or
save him for last yeah I just don't
think Trump's going to be indicted we
had
about that let's see Jose Mendoza
suggesting that if we reach 2500 patrons
I would do a show in a clown suit I'd
consider that I'd consider that someone
else suggesting I do a show nude if we
hit 2500 patrons I don't think so I
don't think that's going to happen what
other questions do we have here it looks
like I had a couple of pints before the
show in addition to just crazy here yeah
someone said that I look like the
ancient aliens guy from the History
Channel show ancient aliens and I
actually do think that there is
something to that I don't have the
ability to real quickly pull up a
picture of that guy but just look up
ancient aliens hair a guy I'm sure
you'll find it and that is funny I think
there's definitely something there
somebody asking me am I mixed I don't
know if that means in my mixed race or
what that could possibly mean but I'm
not mixed race I did a DNA test I'm 97%
Ashkenazi Jewish so I I guess that does
not make me mixed-race what else do we
have here
other questions and comments David could
we pay you enough to wear a mohawk with
a straight face I wouldn't do that I
would maybe I'd consider getting you
know like 22 if we get to 2250 patreon
contributors doing a mohawk type of
thing what other questions are here more
comments than questions really someone
asking if we accept Russian rubles we do
not directly but PayPal does basically
convert any currency into US dollars for
us so that I don't think would be a
problem a couple people getting banned
which isn't a bad thing 3,000 patrons
David does a nude show I just don't
think the nude show is going to really
happen shirtless maybe if we got to like
10,000 patrons but nude I just don't see
happening okay so there it is we've got
a to British Pound super chat from Kenna
Aga Khan ooh I'm sure I didn't pronounce
that correctly
ah so the show is a collective I don't
know what you mean by that the show
is a collective it's a collective of
people for sure but I'm not I'm not sure
what you mean other than than that I
don't know if that means like is it a
co-op or something like that it's not if
you're asking if it's a co-op it's not a
co-op yeah not sure exactly what else is
meant there let me send out a big THANK
YOU to Lindsey Rasmussen Lindsey
Rasmussen has signed up at david
pakman.com slash membership and thank
you Thank You Lindsey really really
appreciate that membership is a top
funding source kind of getting bummed
out though because we're not getting any
new patrons I was hoping that we might
maybe get to 2035 patrons during the
stream today but it it is not happening
it has not happened so far and I am
bummed out that we're not getting any
new contributors but maybe we'll get a
few by the Android's we're just looking
for a couple bucks here and there really
not a big deal let me address what
programs I'm watching now a couple
comments about am i watching this show
am i watching that show
I am currently watching mr. robot season
3 I really like mr. robot I think it's a
very good show I'm watching season three
of mr. robot I am only a couple of
episodes in so far so please no spoilers
I'm gonna watch episode 3 of season 3
maybe tonight okay
I am watching the Colombian version of
it's sort of like the canoe I call it
the Colombian version of narcos about
Pablo Escobar but it actually predates
the narcos series it's called it but
their own made model and it's good I
think it's in a lot of ways better than
narco so I'm watching that
I'm waiting for I'm no longer waiting
for the last season of house of cards
because the last season of house of
cards was season 5 there will be no
season 6 as a result of the Kevin Spacey
sexual harassment and attempted
you know making a pass at a kid I don't
even know what to call it so there will
be no season six I'm no longer waiting
for that I am waiting for the what I
believe is the last season of the
Americans speaking of trump Russia the
last season of the Americans or maybe
the second to last that is going to be
coming up at some point better call Saul
better call Saul as a program i watch
but we are in between seasons right now
and I'll admit that I do watch the
blacklist with James Spader it's a
completely over the top and kind of
wacky show but I really like James
Spader so I am watching that I think it
is in season four four five or is it
three yeah I don't know now so those are
the shows I'm watching right now and
liking them liking them we have a super
chat from a tech dive TV $10 super chat
if Trump resigns couldn't he still be
indicted the the resignation is not
related to the indictment that is
correct but I still don't think Trump is
going to be indicted I think the path
forward for Trump if Trump Russia
continues to explode is a resignation
Chris Harris sent a $5 Super chat do you
feel that people say thoughts and
prayers after a tragedy because they
feel like they're doing their part I
don't know I mean listen it's fine to
say thoughts and prayers the problem I
have with Trump doing it after the Texas
incident is that after the New York
incident it was the the terrorist is an
animal we got to block people from
coming in we got to do this we got to do
that we got to hit Isis harder in the
Middle East
after this incident it's just oh it was
an an event of evil an incident of evil
and thoughts and prayers and that's
basically it right and it's not
terrorism or anything like that and it
may well not be what we would describe
as terrorism by its definition but isn't
it all terrorism when you show up in
your haphazardly shooting you know
dozens of people so yeah I don't have a
problem with people saying you're in my
thoughts you're in my prayers I just
think that when it comes to the double
standard around these reactions the
entire prayers thing
has become a little bit played out in my
mind that's that's really the issue that
I have with it and if people pray that's
fine right if that if that is how
someone feels that they're doing their
part then do it I don't believe that
that does anything but let's let's be
clear that none of what's happening is
related to whether people are worshiping
the right religion or not or anything
like that after all this happened to
people that were praying in a Christian
Church right I think that we cannot
understate that point enough this
happened to people praying in a
Christian Church and yet what now is
being pointed to as we need more guns in
churches well if it's a holy place then
can't you have the protection of God
when you're there so I think that that's
not a helpful narrative I think the
helpful narratives are we can talk about
mental health but specifically we need
to talk about how to prevent people with
mental health issues and criminal issues
from getting guns right because
ultimately it was still the gun that
allowed this person to kill the number
of people that they did the entire good
guy with a gun narrative I mean that
that narrative
I am already sick and tired of because
again we have a situation here where
ultimately the shooter died of a
self-inflicted gunshot wound there is
every indication that the shooter was
already done shooting people at the time
that this good guy with a gun shot him
and further there was a high-speed chase
that individuals completely untrained in
high-speed vehicle situations but
decided to participate in and
fortunately because this was such a
rural area they didn't end up running
anyone over injuring or killing anyone
else but the idea of celebrating that as
the path forward in preventing gun
deaths is a fantasy think about Vegas
think about the pulse nightclub dark
loud and packed in Florida think about
the Aurora Colorado movie theater
shooting a dark room so that that if
we're relying on that to save us we've
got a major major problem and and I
believe we do have a major major problem
here in the United States at stream
labs.com slash the david pakman show a
user going by the name putin loves you
david sent a dollar 72 contribution with
the question have you
seen the get me Roger stone documentary
yet yeah you know I started watching it
on Netflix I got about halfway through
and then things have just been so busy
lately and I've been so distracted that
I have not watched the second half of it
but yes I started to watch it and it's
pretty fascinating although it is also
kind of it's really about the
personality of Roger stone which is fine
right I mean it's kind of a quirky guy I
don't know how much I'm gonna learn from
it but it is very interesting so I do
recommend that you check it out I'm
enjoying it and I think that it would be
[Music]
something good for anybody who's
interested in politics to check out let
me say thank you to a new David Pakman
show member Eddie Evans has signed up at
david pakman.com slash membership opting
not to use the coupon code
I voted 17 but the coupon code is of
course available to you that coupon code
saves you 40% you get 100% of the member
benefits but you get a 40% discount
that's pretty good that's pretty good I
think that a lot of people would would
enjoy that and I think that that is a
it's a coupon people say Oh David should
i do patreon or should i do membership
do whichever you're willing to do right
the whichever is excessive to you
whether you don't like the idea of
giving patreon your payment information
or you like the idea of patreon but not
the idea of using paypal for membership
or whatever it makes no difference to me
we it's a it's a similar fee for both
maybe the fee is slightly lower for
membership because patreon does get a
little bit of a fee
whichever right we just want as many
people involved as possible and which of
the two systems you use is neither here
nor there people continue to ask and
even in the Chad oh you know what let me
address this because people are asking
stuff about dave rubin and on the friday
show we're gonna be taking an audience
question about where i come
on the jimmy dore versus sam cedar
controversy and i'm not gonna go into
the whole explanation but i don't think
it'll be surprising to most people in my
audience that i am coming down on that
to the extent that i care about it on
the sam cedar side okay i I think that
I'm not I'm just not a fan of Jimmy
doors
okay I'm think that his brand of
politics the Trump Russia denial the I
just find it to be all a little bit
unhinged and so I'm gonna give go into
more detail about that on Friday but as
far as all the classical liberal stuff
that's going on I don't have a problem
with people running a business and doing
whatever it is they want to do in order
to grow an audience and make a living
and whatever the problem I have is with
these adherents that jump on to phrases
like progressive left or classical
liberal or whatever else when they don't
really even understand what the terms
mean and they don't really understand
anything about anything but they think
that they're well-read because they've
read a book by poun o--'s who ever write
I mean I don't even care who it is and
it's part of what I described is the
pseudo intellectualism that's really
problematic anti-intellectualism has
been a problem in the United States for
decades if not you know whatever amount
of time you want to put it put it put
timeline you want to put on it but anti
intellectualism is something we can deal
with in one way and a lot of those
people that are anti intellectual they
have no pretension about being
well-informed well-read or sophisticated
in their thinking and they don't think
that it matters and fine okay that that
we can deal with that in a very specific
way the pseudo intellectualism I think
is much more dangerous pseudo
intellectual ism is the people who read
an iron Rand book and think that they've
figured out libertarianism in the path
forward for the you know
benefit of all societies it's people who
read a book by Bill O'Reilly or Mark
Levin or Laura Ingraham and think that
they are sophisticated thinking people
and it might sound like I'm being
elitist and that's really not my
intention
I'm trying to point out that sometimes a
little bit of knowledge is really really
dangerous compared to no knowledge
whatsoever so yeah I I think that the
pseudo intellectualism is a bigger
problem than the anti intellectualism in
the country and I think that these
movements these movements of classical
liberalism these movements of the real
left versus the whatever a I think that
those are incredibly problematic and
they they lead in a way to people like
Donald Trump getting elected so yeah I I
think it's a it's a major major problem
Kristina has sent to stream labs calm
slash the david pakman show contribution
that's why good guys with guns should
also have night-vision goggles on at all
times the answer is more equipment right
yeah if a good guy with a gun wouldn't
obviously have been a benefit in the
Aurora Colorado movie theater shooting
it the solution is not only more people
with guns but you always wear night
vision goggles well said Christina I
kena a share a Kanu sent a dollar
contribution through stream labs I see
you didn't get my collective joke I was
referring to you talking about the lack
of an authority figure that could pull
the show at any moment okay apologies I
did I did miss the reference or the joke
but I appreciate the contributions
nonetheless and now I get it now I get
it thank you very much let me say a
major thank you to the top stream labs
contributors of all time by donation
amounts the top contributor still is
Eric Patterson with two hundred and
fifty four dollars contributed through
stream labs comm slash the David Pakman
show
mm-hmm Clark one two three four who
contributes under probably at this point
close to a dozen different usernames is
in second place with a hundred and $8.99
and Kristina with 46
dollars contributed in third place in
terms of the number of country
contributions it's clarf one two three
four with 41 contributions Cristina with
37 contributions and a couple different
people tied at7 contribution so I like
that super Chet doesn't keep track of
this
but stream Labs does and I like it I
think it's cool to be able to see
contributions over time
and speaking of Cristina she is asking
whether I will ever write a book I have
been talking to a literary agent and
there is definitely an interest that I
have in writing a book I need to figure
out what it would be and it needs to be
authentic right I don't want to redo
something that's been done and I also
want to do something that I really could
be bringing a unique perspective to
because if I'm not then it's kind of
like anybody could write the book so I
don't know exactly what the book should
be about that's that's the main issue
and you kind of need to know what the
book should be about ok let's go back
over to super chat we have a $2.00 super
chat from summer David I've learned so
much from you thank you well I
appreciate that thank you
Matthew Cummings has sent two $5 super
chat how big of a problem in general is
tribalism in political discourse how do
you work around it yet tribalism is a
problem the degree to which it's a
problem we we could kind of debate the
way to work around that is by
understanding cognitive biases by having
a background and and learning about
epistemology and critical thinking and
media literacy and examining our beliefs
to see whether we have ingrained beliefs
because of tribalism or not that that's
sort of the general approach Sophie
Faraday has sent a ten dollar super
cheque not sure if you're aware but you
seem pretty impatient with callers
sometimes at least when they aren't
direct with their questions I honestly
think it's funny though listen I I've
dealt with this before this criticism
before I have ultimate respect for
viewers of the program
particularly people who are willing to
call in and ask questions and sort of
put themselves out there but I am
running a show and to some degree I've
got to keep things moving forward I like
to think that at least to some degree I
can sense when the audience's eyes would
start glazing over from someone who
can't get to their question it is a
question segment right it's a it's a
live question segment it's not live
monologues live screeds diatribes or
soliloquy segments so to some degree
I've got to keep the momentum going
forward and I want to spend as much time
dealing with the question itself and you
know every once in a while someone says
that I'm rude to callers I think
generally speaking I am I'm more than
cordial with callers even callers who
are calling to troll so I know you're
saying you think it's funny I it's not
that I'm impatient it's that we're doing
a timed show right the show is not just
on YouTube it's on radio stations where
it's an hour show it's on TV stations
where it's an hour show if a caller
spends three minutes setting up their
question that that's not good for
anybody it's just not and so I do try to
move them along and I don't I think I'm
gonna leave it there I don't have I
don't have more to say
christina has sent another dollar stream
lapse contribution I miss one live
stream and I fall behind the number of
donations I will come back one dollar at
a time I will I know you will Christina
and says he canal is checking in says he
is an all-star at this point with a
twenty five dollar super chat now the
high-water mark for this live stream
thanks very much ceci appreciate it
always great to hear from you and always
great to see you on the streams and a a
great long time contributor what else
can I say let me do a couple thank-yous
we've got a couple new members that I do
want to thank because membership is such
a big deal
Brian White has signed up while we've
been chatting at david pakman.com slash
membership Kevin Schroeder and Kevin
Smith I it would be so amazing if it was
Kevin Smith
the movie director but because this
individual used the I voted 17 40
percent discount code and because Kevin
Smith's net worth is let's see according
to Google is it 25 million dollars no
that's just what he made off of one
movie I think now what listen the the
real Kevin Smith so to speak is a very
very wealthy guy I can't imagine if he
became a david pakman show member he'd
use the 40% coupon code so in that case
I say thank you and welcome to this
Kevin Smith
not the movie director who I'm a fan of
I am a fan oven when I was younger I
really liked that Jay and Silent Bob
strike back film that was a doozy
that was a doozy haven't seen it for a
long time alright that's it for this
live stream I've got to cut it a little
short I've got a lot of stuff to prepare
for tomorrow's program thanks to
everybody who joined me patreon
membership stream labs super chat
cryptocurrency whatever we've lost a lot
of revenue sources this year but thanks
to your help we are slowly $1 at a time
making them up and I'm confident we'll
continue doing it talk to you on the
next live stream